-White House Press Secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
holds a lot of press briefings,
but I don't think they've asked
all the questions
we need answers to,
so we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go,
so without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night
White House Press Briefing."
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Madam Secretary!
Madam Secretary!
Yes, yes, Ms. Sanders,
thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders,
would you like to open
with some nonsense
to try and distract us
from the fact
that the world is burning?
-We're excited
to announce today that Natalie
and her 8-year-old cousin Celia
will be coming
to the White House on March 23rd
to work with the White House
kitchen staff.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's good nonsense.
Moving on, President Trump
fired Rex Tillerson today.
What did he do during his time
at the White House?
-Served out
his 12-month sentence.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-When President Trump
is hiring someone for his staff,
what does he want to see
on their résumé?
-Organized
in transnational crime,
gang violence,
and other crimes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There seems to be
a lot of chaos
in the White House these days.
What's going inside
Trump's head right now?
-I would never
presume to understand
anything going on
with that individual.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Has --
[ Cheers continue ]
Has the Stormy Daniels scandal
caused Trump to curb
his adulterous behavior?
-President Trump's position on
trophy hunting remains the same.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-If you wanted to hide something
where nobody would ever find it,
where would you put it?
-Under President Trump's
leadership.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What does Melania
hope to accomplish
during her time as First Lady?
-The goal is to get free.
[ Laughter ]
-What's been, of all of them --
out of every single experience,
what's been your favorite moment
of working
in the White House so far?
-None of them.
[ Laughter ]
-What will happen
if Stormy Daniels
releases those lurid photos?
-We're gonna look.
[ Laughter ]
-Just for scheduling purposes,
when is the impeachment?
-The event will take place
Monday, April 2nd,
on the South lawn.
Families with children
13 years old and younger
are invited to join.
-Oh, that's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fun for the whole family.
-Does working
in this White House
age people prematurely?
-I'm 11 years old, almost 12.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
Wow.
When President Trump
got married,
did he mean it when he said
"Till death do us part"?
-The President
was clearly joking.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it true that President Trump
got a new snow-cone machine
for the Oval Office?
-ISIS is being crushed
like it wasn't before.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Sorry.
Did you say ice or ISIS?
[ Laughter and applause ]
All right.
Can you finish this popular
children's nursery rhyme?
♪♪ If you're happy
and you know it... ♪♪
-Get a warrant to spy
on American citizens.
[ Laughter ]
-Any ideas
for a "Home Alone" reboot?
-Kevin should be preventing
terrorists and contraband
from entering the nation.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
Last question.
Where does Melania
pretend she is
when she makes love
to her husband?
-Under Obama.
-O-o-o-o-o-o-okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Looks like we're out of time,
so on behalf of the rest
of the press corps,
have a good night.